have you ever made a movie for more than
250,000 no okay and have people said
there's just no way you're gonna do this
then oh yeah I mean I talk to people all
the time who are experienced - you know
micro-budget to them is half a million
quarter of a million is kind of like
that's the lowest they'll go and they
just can't conceive of it I mean if I
priced out my movies for what you know
they they would cost under normal
circumstances and I would say yeah I did
a quarter of a million half half a
million every time but you know we just
we we plan smart and we shoot you know
the scenes that we need to shoot and we
work within our limitations and embrace
them so I mean I've had I can't tell you
like how many times I don't think I've
had a film shoot even with pickups go
past 16 days most of it I'm in our last
film we shot principal in I think it was
10 or 11 days and then did - two days of
pickups we just were a very efficient
group we didn't work over 14 hours that
I can recall if we did then we may have
been one day most of it's 12 12 13 or
Vegas fed you know you just you just
roll with it yeah I would love to I'd
love to have a quarter of a million
dollars yeah well you could probably now
when you read this script when you say
what's more important or what do you do
first this the script or the budget so
you can probably see red flags like oh
this is gonna really cost or this is
great it's gonna keep it down yeah and
then and then that's a conversation with
the writer you have to talk to him and
say hey you know do we want to are you
open to the idea of changing this given
the given the resources we have
financially because you know we kind of
did an analysis general over and out
Alison's gonna take this many number of
days to shoot so it's got fixed costs in
there you know daily rates for everybody
putting people up then we've got you
know whatever
other things we have to do how many
actors we have to bring in that kind of
thing and and and you should fight for a
compromise but it's one that is a shared
vision as opposed to you're right and
they're wrong so but when I read scripts
today I'm definitely looking at that and
I'm like just seeing it add up and I'm
like okay locations days you know
there's ways you can do some bringing
consolidation and stuff like that so
it's not all like you know when you're
reading in the full story you just go oh
there's only like four locations here
for a main location that's easy makes it
look like it moves around a little bit
more you know that kind of stuff and
it's just I don't determine my working
on something in terms of what budget I'm
gonna do it at first right but I'm gonna
access it from a story level and see
what are the story points that we need
to hit that you know maybe you don't
have a chase scene or if we have a chase
scene we shoot a certain way so like the
the chasing in our movie when you know
he goes to pick up the girl and they
shoot right okay
you know I would have loved to have done
a whole bunch of other stuff there but
that's it and it still worked it still
worked but I had to do you know certain
angles and and and you know just to sell
the idea and and in the in the editing
room you know Edgar knew this but when
he was shooting it and then they had
story you know they had done the shot
list out they figured that we can make
it we can sell this in a day we can do
all of that in one day in actually a
half a day we shot that entire chase and
rundown scene in a half a day and in it
and it worked so yeah you get there's
there's ways to get around it but you
just have to be creative is your goal
moving forward to go past a $250,000
budget or are you content staying here
and knowing that I'm gonna tell stories
that I want to tell we're gonna find
financing our way and not be beholden to
more money more problems money yeah I
mean it's really like if there's
something that comes along that I'm
really passionate about and
you know I see that we can do it for X
and I'm like okay are we do we want to
do this do we do we want to do it
without a script supervisor in the first
ad
I mean Edgar does that you know and
while he's directing how so yeah I mean
that's that's that's the hard part but
in reality it's not about like now we've
graduated this level and now I can't you
know I've never looked at it that way I
just roll up my sleeves I do wardrobe I
do props I'm doing look you know I like
doing everything wherever there's a hand
that's needed right and it's not because
I love doing that but it's needed
otherwise I got to come up with that
cash for somebody else to do it
so in short yes I would like more money
because I'd like to give the time that
we would love to have where we could do
you know all of the things that we have
to cut out in editing because we didn't
have enough time or we didn't get the
actor to be able to get to that that you
know we didn't have the time to get the
actor to be able to get to that that
level that we wanted and we had to we
only had a certain number of texts so we
could do for that shot because of the
limitations of the budget and time these
are the things that you have to plan out
and know what you're doing in order to
execute that and still get a good you
know finished product but money doesn't
always solve that so if it's the crux of
the issue is money then I think you're
gonna fail if it's innovation and
knowing what your resources are and
where you need to put them you know what
scenes you need to focus on so as a
director if you're focused on getting
Academy Award winning moments every
single take and every single scene
you're gonna be in deep trouble because
because in reality you have certain
story points where you definitely need
to work with the actor and you
definitely need to build that up because
if the story the point of where you're
at in the story is very important
because you're coming to the end of the
film where everybody is is writing now
in that during you know they follow the
first and second act now we're in the
homestretch and everything has to pay
off so you don't want to compromise
where you have to you know go oh my god
I spent all of my time up front here
front-loaded in the story where I really
needed to be the most impactful is in
this area where I'm seeing the
revelations and all of the you know all
of the turns that are coming all this
structure that we talked about in the
screenwriting all of that has to hit so
you have to make choices because of the
limitations if you have more money you
can you can just expand on that gives
you more breathing room gives you other
personnel to come in to take the the
concentration of a director and just
focus it solely on the actors not having
to think about the schedules not having
to think about you know where we are in
the script the continuity that kind of
stuff it it's it's really remarkable I
mean I know it's when people see our
films and they go oh my god I can't
believe you guys did that with such a
small crew in so many few days and so
little money that didn't just happen it
was because it was planned and I gave a
lot of that credit to Edgar because he's
really great with that I mean out of
necessities had to do it but the only
reason why I would want more money is so
that his entire focus could be working
with the actors getting him to the
emotional beats that he that he that he
really is like desiring because he knows
he gets excited by the potential of what
he's seen come out and come through and
working with them and and it's a trust
and it's such a beautiful thing I mean
as a producer I I may never direct a
movie but I can always enjoy the trust
between an actor and a director working
together and I want to finance that
potential I want to make sure that that
money is put in the in the appropriate
places to get the maximum impact so that
when the audience sees it they're like
whoa they're blown away like that was a
great performance that was real
that was I I felt I was there that's
what I'm going for
so if it comes at like thirty thousand
or fifty or a hundred or two hundred or
whatever it is or millions more the same
the same result should should occur if
you do everything correctly if you fight
if you follow what your passions are you
do all those points that I talked about
I don't think you can fail you're gonna
learn a lot you may make mistakes but I
don't think you will fail I think you'll
stumble you'll stumble forward to
finish line with a with a very good
product that can be enjoyed not only
through the journey of doing that
project but by the people who are going
to receive it and see it and take
something from it
you